a royal welcome
for the three-time Oscar nominee Helen
Mirren and the two-time Oscar winner Tom
Hanks
well if you've ever put down a book and
thought to yourself not that would make
a great movie while you're at step one
of being nominated for Best Adapted
Screenplay there are only 1,200 other
steps first admit that you were
powerless over alcohol and your life has
become unmanageable step 2 Tom Tom Tom
oh ho those are the wrong steps well we
will just skip to the last one when you
hear your name announced as one of the
nominees along with just a tiny excerpt
of your script here are this year's Best
Adapted Screenplay Sacha Baron Cohen
antony hines peter bainham Dan Mazer and
todd phillips for bharat cultural
learnings of america for make benefit
glorious nation of Kazakhstan based on
characters created by Sacha Baron Cohen
Alfonso Cuaron Timothy J Sexton David
errata mark Fergus and Hawk Ostby for
children of men based on the book by PD
James William Monahan for the departed
based on the film Infernal Affairs Todd
Field and Tom Parata for little children
based on the novel by Tom karate Patrick
Marber for notes on a scandal based on
the book by Zoe Heller and the Oscar
goes to
william monahan for the departed
william monahan based his screenplay
about Boston mobsters on the Japanese
film Infernal Affairs
I'll hold on to this point will you okay
there's no place to put this down huh
well uh valium does work um
haha anyway I was going to cut up the
beginning of the speech and make it
brief but I'm going to leave it back in
and say you know the movie that made me
want to be a screenwriter was Robert
bolts Lawrence of Arabia and I don't
know what could have happened in the
universe to end up at the same Oscars as
Peter O'Toole you know so it's crazy
okay Azir I've seen him so anyway thanks
to the Academy to Warner Brothers
everybody at Warner Brothers Alan Mac
and Felix Chung who wrote Infernal
Affairs the producers present and not
present the agents everybody who made
the departed such a success thanks to
Marty and Leo for reading the script and
calling each other in San let's make it
and Thelma and you know everyone who
worked on the departed was you know it's
easy to say on the top of their game
before they started and you don't under
Mars direction it only got higher after
that thank you very much
Chris Conway backstage here where the
elite filmmakers being celebrated
tonight would never consider this show
to be a mere horse race
so we'll do it for them with the help of
the latest technology see with nine
categories down already we have one
Oscar won by the departed letters from
iwo jima Dreamgirls and little miss
sunshine plus out of 9 categories
already three surprises in Best Animated
Short Best Animated Feature and Best
Supporting Actor a lot more to come like
a battle royale in costume design and
more fun to come right you bet Chris
more fun absolutely don't go away